Okay, so we've got our awesome
prototype, and we've got our excitement.
And we know what information we want to
get out of the user research process.
We're all ready to go.
The only problem is we haven't
found any users to test with yet.
Where do we find those users?
Remember the idea of
circles of feedback?
In this version of the app,
we're going to target the circle
that is closest to you.
That means friends, family or coworkers.
However, we don't want just anyone.
Some people don't always
give good feedback.
For instance, my dad will pretty
much always tell me that anything I
build is great, so
I can't rely on him for
feedback on what's
wrong with an app idea.
Also, people who are technical or design
focused will often delve straight into
solutions without giving
their raw reactions.
This means that their feedback is
often less valuable at this stage.
The ideal person to ask for feedback
on the app concept and execution
is someone close to you who does not
build app or design apps on their own.
If you work in an office, HR and
marketing can often give
really good user feedback.
If you don't,
you can often find a family member or
friend who is not in
the business of building apps.
Oh, and one more thing, be sure that
this is someone you have easy access to.
Prototyping is a fast process, and
you'll want to get feedback
as soon as possible.
Ideally, this is someone you
can talk to later today.
A family member in a faraway land
is not going to be quite as helpful
as your neighbor who
you can talk to now.